now EU lawmakers are holding a ceremony
to award the people of Ukraine the
annual Sakura of prize for freedom of
thought and we're just about to see live
pictures of the ceremony in the European
Parliament the prize which is named
after the late Soviet dissident Andre
sakharov honors individuals and
organizations defending human rights and
fundamental freedoms
and this of course is the Ukrainian
president zielinski DW asked people in
the streets of Kiev Ukraine what they
think about the award
it's right we got it we are the bravest
our army the strongest in the world
I feel grateful and I hope that as well
as words we will receive concrete
support because Ukrainian people are
really brave but we need the support of
the world
I think it's good this is the definition
of everything happening here right now I
think it's recognition of the dignity
and heroism of the Ukrainian people
Ukraine now is considered one of the
leading countries in Europe and is going
to develop more together with the
European countries and I think this
prize will have a good effect on the
future of our country
our face is to be brave
and joining us now from Strasbourg is DW
correspondent
Visa Barbara we saw um footage just now
of President zielinski I believe
receiving the prize on behalf of the
Ukrainian people uh what more can you
tell us about it
I mean this price for the European
Parliament is a really big occasion
every year because they are trying to
sort of focus on their work as Defenders
of Human Rights what they want to do
parliamentarians say is shine a light on
dissidents on people who give their
lives and and work for the defense of
Human Rights and of Liberty and so this
is of course if you look at last the
last year's Prize winner was Alexey
navalny the year before it was the
opposition in Belarus so they have quite
a track record of sort of really looking
to Eastern Europe and of course the
European Parliament has been from the
beginning of the war the staunchest
defender of Ukraine within the European
institutions they have really uh sort of
strengthened to try to strengthen the
will of the member states to support
Ukraine to to give money to give weapons
countless resolutions in support of
Ukraine and so there really trying to to
set a symbol here and let people know
that the work is not done it's ongoing
but it is still extremely important we
just heard some Ukrainian voices there
giving us their thoughts about the prize
can you tell us how receiving this prize
is likely to affect the Ukrainian people
what what psychological impact might it
have
I mean the psychological impact of
course for the people who have come to
take the price here because there is
quite a number of Super Society
organizations that are represented here
for them this is extremely important
this is this is an acknowledgment that
they exist that the acknowledgment of
their fight and the acknowledgment of
their work for instance the Emergency
Services of Ukraine who are working so
relentlessly after every bomb attack one
of their representatives is here the
emergency evacuation the medical
evacuation unit who is just incredibly
heroic pulling people out of the rubble
one of their people is here to to take
the price and then of course we also
have a person that is the mayor of
Miller to Paul the occupied City and he
very early on in the occupations stood
up to the Russian occupiers and he said
that he would rather be in in jail and
be rather be taught should then work
with Russia because they were the enemy
of the Ukrainian people let's listen to
what Evan federov had to say about his
struggle
it is very important now for our nation
because now our nation our citizens
people in Ukraine need support and need
to feel this support in different levels
from different kinds because ukrainians
defend for values for European values
first of all
looking at the fighting in the region
now it's Fierce on one hand on the other
hand it seems to be troops seem to be
bogged down because of the winter so
what are your predictions what are your
hopes for the next weeks and few months
you know I think that by last 10 months
as uh Ukrainian militaries Ukrainian
salts and Ukrainian Nation show that
nobody can predict this such heroism
ukrainians will defend their land nobody
predict that Ukraine will liberate kiske
region chernigan nobody predicted our
soldiers liberate harkev that's why I
think that nobody can predict when we
liberate but they also need support and
first of all military support we need
enough weapons winning ones have enough
heavy equipment to defend our territory
if we will have enough support from our
partners we will defend on winter summer
and of course
we'll celebrate together our victory
Barbara very clear that Ivan Federer of
talking about the support Ukraine needs
tell us more about what this support
needs to look like
I mean the support is just an ongoing
labor we saw this donor conference
yesterday in Paris where another billion
euros was collected in order to help UK
Ukraine get through the winter for
generators electric equipment repair
equipment endless lists of necessities
and on the other hand of course there's
the ongoing need of weapons because both
sides Russia and Ukraine are in the
process of running down their stocks so
Ukraine needs more deliveries they are
getting for instance heavy weapons from
the United States for the high Mars are
on the way that's what we heard but
other European countries need to keep
delivering weapons because otherwise
what Ivan fedorov hopes that there will
be a celebration of Victory will not
come to pass DW
correspondents Strasbourg thank you